what's going on guys this is rob and i'm
gonna make you guys an expert on clea
because i feel like there are a lot of
people who want to know who this
character is and don't really know
anything about her here's the funny
thing clea is more powerful than steven
strange she's
really powerful and a lot of that has to
do with basically her lineage as far as
like dormammu and umar and the fact that
she's like related to them so we'll get
to that here in a minute but first
things first of course cleo was created
by stan lee and steve ditko and first
appeared in strange tales issue number
126 in 1964. now here's the thing to
understand about clea clea is what we
call a character who kind of broke the
mold to a degree right she was born in
that in that ideology and then went on
to change it one of the things to know
those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with comics one of the things to know
when it came to women in comics they
were either damsels in distress or they
were essentially sex objects right like
objects of affection wonder woman is a
perfect example of that when she was
created way back in the day she was
usually designed and written in such a
way to where she was by all standards of
measurement a lustful character of
course wonder woman was really the first
one to actually break that mold but
after her there were characters like
clea there was carol danvers rogue but
clea is one of those characters that
kind of led the way in terms of how her
character progressed that essentially
elevated women from just being like this
girl that had to be saved by like the
main male hero to being being the kind
of girl that could like hold her own
right they could do her own thing um so
the way that stan lee and steve ditko
originally wrote this is that in strange
tales issues 126 and 127 it was actually
a two-part story and this is one of
those scenarios where marvel essentially
introduced two characters both of which
would go on to become mainstays in the
doctor strange mythos the first of
course was clea and the second was
dormammu now at the time of course
because this was the first appearance of
dormammu we didn't really have him
fleshed out we just knew he was really
powerful and like right off the bat it's
established that way right that
essentially steven strange is sent to
the dark dimension to face off against
dormammu who of course as he's warned by
the ancient one is a being of immense
power who continually tries to invade uh
the main marvel universe and this is
just his most recent attempt to do it
but the first time stephen strange is
facing off against him now one of the
things to solidify here is that at the
time the ancient one is alive which
means the ancient one is the source for
supreme stephen strange is just his
disciple uh but in essence stephen
strange traveled there and then was
spotted by clia and with her not really
knowing who he was one of the first
things this solidified is that contrary
to what you may believe the dark
dimension is not simply just a place
where dormammu resides it's a whole it's
a whole like dimension there are people
who live there right all kinds of beings
that live in this place and i think
that's one of those things that people
have a tendency to overlook and it makes
sense because you don't really see a lot
of reference to it whenever you have
some kind of situation unfolding that
deals with the dark dimension it
basically only deals with dormammu or
sister umar and like that's basically it
you know there really isn't a whole lot
more than that as well as the mindless
ones um now again we can kind of cook
the books a little bit here and sort of
inject some information that didn't
readily exist at the time the nature of
dora mamu is he is what you call a
falatinian or a fountain essentially he
hails from what's called the fall team
dimension he and his sister umar they
are basically beings of pure magical
energy which means they're wildly
capable now dormammu is not some end-all
be-all all-encompassing magical being
right he's not some unstoppable force
just because he's a being made of a pure
magical energy does not mean he's the
most powerful magical being out there
and i know it seems a little weird but
there are individuals out there that are
more powerful than he is some of them
are people like sidorak for example or
someone like cathone um a lot of this is
because of the fact that they were able
to access aspects of magic that dormammu
simply just can't access himself now
initially we didn't know why this is
something that actually changed later on
and we'll talk about this with the
nature of clea because marvel uses as a
way to sort of clear up why it is
adoramamoo is not some all-encompassing
magical being that can never truly be
defeated because he's made of pure magic
uh before the story itself clia not
really knowing who doctor strange is
having never seen him before basically
watches him as he faces off against
dormammu and even intervenes
occasionally kind of telling him you
can't defeat this guy right like this
guy door mama who's on a whole different
level of power and the reality is steven
strange at this point in time can't
really beat dormammu right dormam is
just too powerful for him and a lot of
that's because once you become sorcerer
supreme your powers elevate because you
basically end up gaining the power of
the vashanti so if this makes any sense
to you when stephen strange became the
sorcerer supreme his power grew four
times over right because it's just the
nature of things right just you know
again the vashanti make up about 80
percent of the sorcerer supreme's power
so his power amplified several times
over which is why he was able to hold
his own against our mommy later on but
back on track here essentially what went
on in this this initial appearance is
that clear didn't really have a whole
lot to offer it was really more of just
kind of her being there and then kind of
warning steven strange a little bit and
if anything the purpose may be served of
offering a kind of damsel in distress
type situation because ultimately
because dormammu becomes aware of the
fact that clea had basically been
assisting stephen strange that dormammu
actually imprisons cleo so that kind of
creates the the damsel in distress
dynamic and then ultimately of course
stephen strange faces off against
dormammu kind of uh the big battle
between the two but in the midst of it
they basically stop and the reason for
that goes into the nature of the dark
dimension itself that while dormammu
does rule this dimension or historically
has ruled that dimension he's only one
part of it it is technically called
what's what's referred to as the
splinter realms but one section of this
is housed by beings or really uh
involves beings that are called the
mindless ones and they're exactly what
they sound like right just these beings
who are powerful but they can't really
think so if you guys saw doctor strange
one kaiselius and all those guys at the
end of the movie when they were whisked
away to the dark dimension they became
the mindless ones right like you
literally saw their eyes disappear and
you just ended up getting that kind of
visor appearance you saw it happen as
they were flying into the dark dimension
but they basically became mindless ones
they just kind of follow the directions
of dormammu to a degree but they also
have sentience and they've been in the
dark dimension before dormammu came
there uh but the way this worked is that
dormammu always had a kind of barrier
that basically kept them at bay the
longer the fight between the two went on
the more the barrier began to weaken and
it basically would leave the landscape
open for the mindless ones to invade the
dark dimension and essentially kill
everybody who resided there and so
steven strange ultimately ended up
lending a portion of his power to
dormammu in order for dormammu to
basically uphold the barrier because
dormammu had essentially exhausted so
much of his energy facing off against
stephen strange and so with khalia
watching on of course dormammu ends up
you know restoring his barrier and then
essentially because he owed doctor
strange a favor he ended up letting him
go and ultimately that was just kind of
the initial introduction of cleo's
character now the funny thing about this
is that while it's not necessarily
official the kind of dormammu epic as i
like to refer to it ran all the way up
to strange tales issue 146. it was not
necessarily a direct series of stories
just kind of an on-again off-again that
essentially came to a conclusion with
strange tales 146 uh but clea and her
role as really being the damsel in
distress really came into full view here
and the reason why is because following
his initial defeat uh i guess maybe
bargain more or less uh with with
stephen strange dormammu had made a made
an agreement right made a vow that was
bound by magic that he would not invade
earth which basically meant that any
attempt that he would make uh really
going forward into the future if it was
a direct attempt on earth his own power
would basically stop him um and so what
this did is it actually led to dormammu
really getting involved with like
earthly beings that were out there the
most popular of course basically being
baron mordo the baron mordo was fighting
steven strange on behalf of dormammu
different things along those lines um
but again this really involved clea
because she was kind of this girl that
was really caught in the middle in a lot
of ways she was used as what was
essentially a weapon against steven
strange a really good example of this is
during the events of uh strange tales
146 where the initial dormammu epic
really came to a head when he was
essentially defeated by eternity that
essentially he had gone mad and
challenged the living embodiment of the
universe and was ultimately defeated the
big deal here and what was really
interesting here though is that as a as
a really a desire to punish stephen
strange for the fact that he had
previously defeated dormammu before
essentially his destruction dormammu had
sent clea away to a place called the
realms unknown and again marvel never
really goes into detail about this it
was you know at least back then was
really just kind of a holding place
where they could send clia until some
future point in time when they could
basically bring her back um and she
wasn't gone very long i mean she was
gone for maybe a couple years but the
thing with umar is that because dormammu
was of course her brother and the idea
was or at least the desire was to see
doramamu essentially eradicated so that
umar would never have to contend with
her brother showing back up in the dark
dimension again and challenging her rule
because by all standards of measurement
dormammu is the more powerful of the two
that clea despite the fact that she had
been rescued in strange tales 146 was
sent back to the realms unknown by umar
so steven strange would chase after clia
and then ultimately destroy dormammu of
course that never really came to
fruition and then what this basically
did is it led to marvel kind of
reworking things in terms of
transforming clea again from being this
kind of damsel in distress to somebody
who was more in line with the direct
role that steven strange played and so
that's why during doctor strange 171 and
173 which is essentially dr strange
volume 1 just kind of a continuation of
the strange tales line to a degree you
basically saw duramamu defeated by
steven strange and then in issue number
174 essentially stephen strange came to
the realization that the only way to
keep clea safe was to keep her close
that he brought her directly to him
right to basically keep her on earth
because as long as she was away from him
especially in the dark dimension those
individuals who were in the dark
dimension would essentially use her as a
pawn as a means to try to get to stephen
strange now one of the things that i do
want to specify here is that by this
point in time despite the fact that his
run only lasted about a year uh this was
during the the time that roy thomas was
writing it now that's an exceedingly
important thing and the reason why is
because uh stan lee does get a lot of
credit when it comes to a lot of the
work that he did at marvel insofar as
either bringing back captain america or
creating thor or helping to create thor
helping to create spider-man different
things like that but the truth about it
is that most modern superheroes as they
exist now in terms of how you see them
when you read comics that was all done
on the shoulders of roy thomas chris
claremont steve englehart people like
that that in a lot of ways stan lee set
the stage but a lot of future writers
were the ones who really evolved the
characters and there was almost nobody
who was as good at that as roy thomas
the fantastic four all that kind of
stuff the guy had massive contributions
and i really say to this day you know i
do have a lot of respect for stan lee he
did a lot of great things but i think
that roy thomas was a larger contributor
to marvel comics than stan lee was but
the thing about this is that roy thomas
loved to focus more heavily on
interpersonal dynamics and that's why
you had clea again being brought to
stephen strange and she ultimately ended
up becoming his apprentice now of course
this followed the events of stephen
strange having to kill the ancient one
in order to prevent shumogorath from
coming into the main marvel universe and
so in effect he ended up becoming the
new sorcerer supreme and so with him
overtaking that role there were a few
things that went on one you ended up
seeing dormammu make a return which
basically led to stephen strange forming
the defenders uh but for clea herself
you saw her basically using her magical
abilities to learn as much as she
possibly could about the nature of magic
itself and so she would constantly study
in the the sentencing torum of stephen
strange and then ultimately you would
basically see her become this wildly
capable practitioner of of magic and
marvel comics now one of the things i
also want to specify here is that at
this point in time we don't have an
origin for clia her origin had not been
established when she was initially
introduced and in fact that wouldn't
come until some number of years later
instead what you saw was really roy
thomas and especially steve inglehart
focusing more on the the two of them
basically growing close this grew by way
of different stories from like doctor
strange volume 2 which was launched in
the 1970s uh the defender stories
themselves things in marvel premiere
especially marvel premiere issue number
12. um that you basically saw these
events unfolding where really a romantic
relationship was blooming between the
two of them and it made sense because
the way that roy thomas had written the
character and kind of again building on
what stanley had done um that the nature
of stephen strange is that he was
oftentimes a rescuer for clea and so
being a rescuer for her basically meant
that a romantic attraction was growing
and so it became a really really cool
thing because what you ended up doing
was going into uh marvel team-up issues
76 and 77 where you started to see the
potential of exactly what it was clea
was capable of albeit under
circumstances beyond her control so this
was under uh steve ingelhardt and what
you ended up getting here was basically
the introduction of a villain named
isaiah kirwin also known as the silver
dagger this guy's got kind of a weird
history it's a it's a little murky
essentially he's tied with like
catholicism and whatnot but he wanted to
learn like the secrets of magic so he
could become like god's favorite on
earth or something on those lines but
ultimately he ended up corrupting uh
clea and in doing so we basically saw
this really really dark and twisted
version of her that was almost identical
to something like dormammu or umar and
it was really the early days of marvel
toying with this idea that clea was
actually tied directly to the falcinian
dimension even though we didn't
necessarily know exactly how that would
play out now of course clear was rescued
and the day was saved and and silver
dagger was defeated and whatnot but what
this did is about 52 issues later going
into the doctor strange vol 2 issue
number 53 is you basically saw clia
being sent back to the dark dimension
now one thing i also want to specify
here it may seem like clea only really
had like a handful of appearances i mean
she didn't she appeared in a lot of
comics i mean there are a lot of doctor
strange stories in between the ones that
we're talking about that she had
appearances in um as well as things like
ghost writer comics and and so on and so
forth right so it's not like she
appeared eight or nine times again we're
just kind of doing the broad strokes
here but under the writing of roger
stern this is when we really got the
first origin or really the origin of
clea in marvel comics with doctor
strange volume 2 issues
71-73 now this was big because what it
showed is that with clia being whisked
back to the dark dimension or being sent
back there again and umar basically
being the one who was ruling that what
you had here was in effect a rebellion
you had those who were loyal to
essentially the azura throne right
basically the the people or the family
that ruled uh the dark dimension before
the arrival of dormammu and umar and the
mindless ones and so on and so forth and
then you had those who were loyal to
umar and dormammu and whatnot um and so
when this happened you basically had
clea who of course took the side of the
rebels against umar not truly knowing
what was going on one of the funny
things here is that with dr strange
being in the dark dimension and really
kind of operating behind the scenes to
fully understand what was going on uh
that it was actually steven strange who
learned from orini who was actually at
one point the lover of uh umar that umar
was the mother of clea and it was a
really really cool revelation here
because what had basically been told is
that irini himself was essentially the
heir to the dark dimension that the way
this had played out is that you had king
ulnar who basically ruled the entire
place and then when the mindless ones
invaded olnar and his wife were killed
by the mindless ones but then when the
mindless ones invaded ulnar and his wife
were killed and orini himself was simply
too young to rule and so the citizens of
the dark dimension had chosen dormammu
and umar to essentially rule in their
stead or at least in in place of aurini
until he was old enough to take the
throne not realizing that dormammu and
umar just wouldn't give up their power
and so as a result of this of course the
mindless ones are basically again
defeated kept at bay by dormammu and
then he sees control and then umar
largely just kind of hung around the
general area uh during this time umar
and orini ended up falling in love not
initially she actually rebuffed him
initially but they ended up falling in
love and then they had clea and umar of
course basically took off and orini
raised his daughter by himself the funny
thing is that in this origin as it's
told that stephen strange and then
really what irini says is if you tell
cleo this it'll kill the rebellion
because she won't have the courage to
face off against her mother of course
steven strange tells clea and she ends
up basically
siding against umar anyway and leaving
the rebellion but the crazy thing is
once she visits her father and then
confronts him with this information her
father actually turns on her and says
like you abandoned your home your
namesake all of this for some guy out
there on earth who practices magic like
you basically turned your back on your
people and so at the end of the day of
course she you know once the the
rebellion is basically over and she
essentially comes out on top she
basically banishes both umar and orini
to another dimension and then clia
becomes the ruler of the dark dimension
so that's how she ends up basically
taking that role in marvel comics she
quite literally defeats her mom in order
to become the ruler of the land
it was really really cool now
undoubtedly people are gonna ask the
question okay so like when did they get
married
[Laughter]
when did uh when did clee and doctor
strange get married okay so there's a
little bit of build up here that we need
to kind of talk about and those people
who are familiar with the silver dagger
story we'll probably kind of be like
okay you skipped over a hugely important
part and i did i kind of wanted to wait
until we got to this segment before we
brought it up during the silver dagger
story arc one of the things that had
happened is that initially at the time
stephen strange had actually been really
challenged by like the essence of death
now you did have like eternity the
ancient one you know people who stepped
in and essentially rescued him but when
he showed back up he didn't actually
have a physical form he simply had an
astral uh in astral form and so what you
ended up getting was actually stephen
strange entering into the body of uh of
clea and the two of them basically
escaping silver dagger now of course
ultimately steven strange found his own
physical form but the reason why that
matters is because what marvel had
illustrated over the years in terms of
the relationship between the two is that
the the kind of connection that stephen
strange and clea had transcended love as
you or i will know it right like between
you and myself and anybody else out
there as normal human beings us normies
non-magic beings
uh love is just a is a combination of
lust and ongoing connection right that's
literally what it is right you see
somebody you're like damn they're hot
but then when you spend enough time with
them that lust turns into genuine love
which turns into i can't imagine what my
life was like without this person uh and
so with with doctor strange and with
clea they had a very
personal connection insofar as for a
time their souls were actually
intertwined and so that connection
continued on and was really established
uh really went into their marriage in
doctor strange sorcerer supreme number
three in 1989. technically this is
volume 3 but normally volumes are like
ongoing series uh this was like a four
issue mini series right because steven
strange or doctor strange is one of
those characters in marvel comics where
the guy the guy couldn't sell he
couldn't hold a book to save his life
[Laughter]
right from like the the mid 1980s going
forward really the end of volume two uh
he always just struggled to be able to
to maintain any longevity in terms of
ongoing publishing or even any
consistent writers uh but during this
time the two of them basically got
married now it was not a marriage in the
traditional sense instead it was one of
those things where they actually created
a singular ring and then it split and
each one of them wore an individual ring
and for the most part their marriage was
never really a nulled not as far as i'm
aware uh they actually ended up staying
married essentially i mean one of the
things that had happened under the
writing of roger stern and even going to
peter gillis and people like that over
the years during this time when the two
of them were together as as a as a
married couple you had clea who
basically ruled over the dark dimension
and you had stephen strange who is the
sorcerer supreme on earth and so because
of their roles they were consistently
apart from one another and so what this
did is it put massive strains on their
marriage because they just weren't
really together all that often i mean
you would see them cross over again you
know i don't want to make the point that
like you wouldn't see clea for any
measure of time you would see them cross
over right you would see doctor strange
helping clea or you would see clea show
up to help doctor strange but it's not
like they were both living in a condo in
midtown
it just didn't really work that way now
one of the funny things about cleo's
character is following really the end of
dr dr strange volume three uh the the
sorcerer supreme storyline she didn't
really reappear for about seven years
between 1995 and 2002 with the order uh
that's when she basically showed back up
again she was there for a little while
but then she just disappeared for
several more years and that was kind of
how it was right with her character she
was in a lot of ways kind of considered
to be a holdover right kind of uh not
really an archaic character but somebody
who just didn't really seem to be
necessary to the doctor strange mythos
now again a lot of this was because
doctor strange was being reshuffled
right so for example when he lost the
title of being sorcerer supreme which
was given to jericho drum also known as
brother voodoo who became dr voodoo and
then eventually steven strange got it
back the near you know the comic bust of
the 1990s marvel almost going bankrupt
and and instead of investing their
resources in characters whose ability to
sell comics were a little bit
questionable they focused largely on
characters they knew would sell and then
just outsourced everything else to event
publications with jimmy palmiotti and
joe quesada it was just one of those
things right where where clea just took
a backseat for a variety of reasons and
so if we're being honest while she did
appear in future stories the more
significant appearance of her story
really didn't show back up again until
essentially marvel one more dayed clea
and steven strange and it's one of those
things that a lot of people don't know
about people think about the idea of one
more day in relation to like spider-man
right that basically a deal was brokered
between mary jane watson peter parker
and mephisto that in order to save aunt
may that essentially their marriage
would be annulled right they would lose
their love and they would seemingly
never be back together again basically
the same thing was done with steven
strange and clia uh that the result of
this is that in order to essentially
save all things in existence again kind
of referencing the events of uh doctor
strange volume five that a deal was
struck that clea would basically lose
any knowledge of her time with steven
strange now this is a really really
important thing because following that
she had just kind of gone back to
essentially being in the dark dimension
and it disappeared for a while i mean
she had appeared kind of but no real
meaningful appearances but that's the
reason why when you go into what's
basically the death of dr strange
storyline that when clia reappears that
she makes these kind of comments like
well at some point in time you would
force me to forget about you and
different things like that that's where
that's from right from from doctor
strange volume five um but again you
know at the moment in marvel comics
following the death of stephen strange
he's no longer part of the picture he
will return right nobody ever stays dead
forever in comics so doctor strange will
come back he will be the sorcerer
supreme somewhere along the line at the
moment is actually clea who is uh who's
sorcerer supreme as i understand it the
story is great i haven't had a chance to
read it yet but i intend to fix that but
by and large this is essentially clea
right again you know there there are
some finer points that we kind of left
out here but uh for the most part this
should be enough to make you an expert
on the character but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end uh thank you all for watching
and i will catch you all later
peace